hello everyone hopefully you guys can
hear me yeah I should be able to hear me
how's everyone to and in robbery trust
oh man how's everybody doing today I
think hopefully you guys can hear me fun
yes you guys can hear me fun oh my
goodness it's been a little while since
we've done one of these it's been like a
month but I've been Catalan so busy it's
one of the reasons what I'm hiring on an
editor is because I need some free time
ignore all that stuff back there i
ordered a whole bunch of frames I got
the oh god what did I get episodes 1 2 3
4 5 & 6 I got those poster frames I got
a poster frame for Avengers Assemble
Avengers number one I got the poster for
a post for the walking dead and those
are written I think so yeah the posters
are pretty badass i'll be hanging them
up i'll be taking some down hanging them
up that kind of stuff and then I think
I'm gonna move because when i bring it
i'm bringing editor in here to be in
this apartment which is gonna be weird I
need to get like a big apartment like a
big loft or something like that but like
I'm probably going to like take the
incredible hulk and the Iron Man posters
and move them put them somewhere else
and similar where people can see him but
I don't I don't know either way like
I'll get it figured out so it has been
so long it's been forever it was funny
all the hassle you guys were giving me
so as you guys know whenever I do my
comics are coffee and okay it's a
helicopter I thought it was like
thundering outside whenever I do my
comic should coffee I really ever drink
coffee for one and two I always listen
to music so here you guys go here's some
some music here's some music for use
that's a mix it up put together is like
half an hour long as whatever but
how often do I shave not often enough
it's actually it's actually pretty
pitiful so let's see the specter puts
you in the tesseract thoughts on
splattered win um-hmm a spider Gwyn's
okay but the spider going doesn't strike
me as like oh my god she's amazing it's
just gonna like Miss buck when she's all
right you know but I'm not a big fan of
spider-man in general so it's not like I
saw a spider Gwen and I was like this
changes everything like it's just like
me yes spider-man um I didn't get a
degree olive in college I was only there
for a couple of years and then I left um
my favorites if Lordan then that's a
good one because there's a lot of really
good ones I'm kind of more I'm more of a
fan of the older ones like Exar Kun then
I am with the new ones like God Vader or
Sidious or I think Jacen Solo became a
Sith Lord in the expanded universe
before d or before disney like canceled
it out at least I think that's what
happened so um why did when I did you
guys for three weeks I didn't ditch you
guys for three weeks I was just super
busy for three weeks thoughts on all new
all different Deadpool well as far as I
know Deadpool hasn't come out the comic
hasn't come out yet I think it comes out
next month but Deadpool and uncanny
Avengers is pretty cool which is which
is pretty awesome um yeah no I think I'm
caning at least what we've seen from
Deadpool so far is a cool idea now I
like the idea that Deadpool is going to
be like the most popular hero on the
planet that's going to be badass yeah
I've heard of one punch man um Jessica
Jones can't wait yeah I can't wait
either I'm pretty psyched favorite Jedi
whew that's gonna that's a tougher one
I'd say you lequel drama because i think
or maybe his cake hell drama it's one of
the cal dramas um they fell to the dark
side and went back to the light side
they were like Darth Vader before Darth
Vader and they were super powerful so
you're not late at all you just arrived
like we just started well I guess you
did just arrived we started a little bit
ago maybe like
minutes ago so you're you're very early
so krysten ritter was a good pic and
here's here's what solidified krysten
ritter for me as an incredible actress I
was watching Breaking Bad and she was
the girl who was a former heroin addict
they got in with with Jesse Pinkman and
he like basically took her back to
heroin addiction and the way the she
portrayed her character was astounding I
me her like her the time that she
started acting to the time as she
finished was incredible you know she was
she was she was pretty fantastic of an
actress um you know that right like that
it was only a few episodes it was only
like three or four episodes as far as i
know but that's the lid apply to her as
an amazing actress in my book so um hey
Robin actually catching you live yes you
are hey Rob what are five essential
Batman comics to read if you want to get
into Batman ooh well um it's actually
really really simple there's Batman zero
year which is a Greg Pak I think it's
correct back which details how Bruce
Wayne became Batman it's the whole back
story of how I became Batman um after
that it's really just getting current i
mean it's its quarterly out it'sit's
they call a quarter the owls but its
core today i was a nine of the owls but
if you go and buy the trade it's all one
big story call the court of the owls and
in truth that's that's that's true none
of the alice is really more like a
branch off of quarter the owls but it's
all one big story so there's a batman
zero year Batman quarter the owls and
then Batman death of the family and then
Batman in game so it's really only like
four four stories but if you want
individual comic books to get into
that's really tough to do because DC
focuses on character arcs and so you
don't really find a lot of like one
shots that encapsulate everything you're
better off just going with trades is
what I would say shuma gorath versus
Dormammu that's a good one adore mama
definitely shuma gorath was staved off
he was he was kind of defeated you know
by dr. strange but I think it was
explicitly stated in like Doctor Strange
volume 3 or some new
vendors or something like that that if
Dormammu ever came back like at full
power that no one would be able to stop
him he would be an undefeatable person
and the main Marvel Universe so um let's
see which is your favourite batman who
mm-hmm I like Batman from the dark
knight returns because he was so dark
and he was a like do whatever it takes
and as any monologue at the end when he
beat Superman and he was like he was
like I just want you to know like I
could have killed you if I wanted to
worsen one of those lines you know like
you're going to remember this moment for
the rest of your life like that was a
cool that was a really badass scene so I
like that Batman the best what do I
think earth well earth to Harrison wells
is going to do I think he's going to be
the eobard thawne that were used to but
it could just be like a time displaced
Harrison wells I mean it could have been
they could they could write it in a such
a way that like Harrison wells you know
from her mojo makalah you know was just
thrown into the time stream or any
number of things you know because I mean
they they said that he was he was just
kind of like he couldn't exist if you
know his descendant or I guess his
ancestor had died with was named Eddie
Thawne um you know if he had died then a
abarth on couldn't exist which is true
it creates a paradox you know but they
could simply just say well you know the
earth to reality came into existence
when ya barde Thawne was killed or I
guess when Eddie killed himself I don't
know they could do any number of things
but I think he's I'm hoping he's going
to be like the eobard thawne that we
know from the flash comics so um I said
yeah I want you remember the man who
beat you that's what it was that's what
it was um black panther or Batman who
will win ooh uh I'm fattened your band
what's that you say you want to get
banned well that guys there you go and
um Batman vs black panther
hmm Batman vs black panther I would say
that see that's a question that people
ask all the time and this is the last
verses when we're going to do this is
last one we're going to do like the last
question I'm an answer about a person
versus a person because I think those
are those aren't you know I don't like
those um for the sake of argument I'd
say Polly Black Panther you know he's ad
he's like the third smartest person in
the Marvel Universe you know I at that
point it's a toss up and it's just kind
of whichever one you like most so um
could I make some rap songs know what I
have a question is a Phoenix going to be
an all-new marvel what are your thoughts
I don't know as far as i know the
beginning x-men stories are literally
the hunt for Cyclops they're trying to
find out where Cyclops is I don't know i
mean the the Phoenix force survive it
depends on how secret wars ends and
that's the problem with with Secret Wars
man is as a problem when Marvel just
like jumps the gun and I guess well I
guess when sick of wars got delayed and
Marvel released on all their stuff ahead
of time you know I guess before Secret
Wars ends as a problem you went into so
you know I don't know who wants to get
banned somebody's who's somebody who's
life doesn't have any value um let's see
someone should make a lightsaber vape
they should oh I think the shot of that
like a lightsaber e-cigarette oh do I
have a pond that like it'd be amazing
like it would light up and everything
what are you going for is Halloween I'm
actually not going for anything myself
Benny I think natalie and Sal are going
to los angeles for halloween weekend so
uh did you follow the Secret Wars siege
and what did you think of it um sick of
where siege I didn't read I didn't I had
no interest in reading that what should
you read to get into the all new Marvel
continuity that is a good one um and
truth it's really kind of what you want
to do but here's a problem and this is
the problem it's not all new all
different Morrible I'm with Benny one
hundred percent of the way when I say
that I think that I guess I agree with
Benny when he said that Marvel was
originally going to like new 52
everything they were just going to stop
it all and wipe the slate clean and
start over but they got cold feet they
backed out and so the result is that now
we have this convoluted crap or people
who like most secret wars just didn't
even need to happen what was the point
of secret works like why you know they
could have just changed rosters up they
could have just done different things I
could have said well now we've got a
multiversal of interest team because the
universe was or the multiverse was
almost destroyed like you know they
could have they could have just done
that instead and so now secret war seems
pointless but nonetheless you know and
you'll notice that too like like with
all new all different level coming out
if you go and look at the sales force
ticket wars you're going to see them
like rapidly drop you're going to see
this just this plummet in terms of the
sales or you might only mine on I mean
people may still be interested but I
think people are not very interested in
secret wars right now and that's that's
obvious because of the fact that like
when I have loaded the secret wars video
people are like to even care about stick
of wars anymore and I was like no no I'm
just finishing it so i can say that it's
done in case anybody ever gets curious
but anyway um with regards to all new
all diff remarkable spider-man is a
continuation of you know Dan slots run
before Secret Wars that's all that is
it's just a continuation let's see what
else is there hyoeun man is kind of new
you know uncanny Avengers is new blue
Marvel is really strong like he's about
he's almost as strong as this entry was
like he's a really powerful character i
think he is about as strong as this
entry was but um yeah no it'sit's you
can kind of grab what you want to and
ignore what you don't want to just be
aware that some of the stories like
spider-man are continuations and so if
you pick it up you're going to be like
well I'm gonna head of a corporation but
you know why are they talking like
Parker industries has been here the
entire time
that's how you're going to run into
that's a problem you're going to have so
um your theory for force awakens oh man
honestly I feel like the force awakens
is really more of a reboot than anything
else that's that's my personal opinion
that's kind of my thought the force
awakens is a cool concept the force
awakens is is gonna be an amazing movie
but I feel like you know getting rid of
the Sith replacing them where at least
as far as we can tell getting rid of the
Sith replacing them with the Knights of
Ren which are kind of a like like an ad
hoc group of Dark Jedi like a you know
like a they're figuring out how to use
lightsabers they have very crude
lightsaber seven things like that or at
least the one we saw kylo Ren have was a
very crude lifesaver it kind of feels
like a reboot to me mmm having said that
I'm pretty sight um actually on Rob
explains I'm probably going to do a
little mini series or maybe just a video
to see how it performs but do something
about you know the journey to the force
awakens because for those of you guys
who don't know it's not as though Disney
is just launching episode 7 and it's
just like done let's see how this does
they're building up this massive expanse
of stuff there's like 20 books dedicated
to like covering in all the gaps between
like episode 1 and episode 7 there's
comic books there's TV shows that are
coming out their cv shows it already
exists you know that cover this huge you
know chunk of time I know that like a
Greg Pak I think no Charles Soule wrote
um or is writing in the midst of writing
Anakin and obi-wan which covers you know
the events between episode 1 and episode
2 when Anakin Skywalker I guess when
qui-gon jinn died and Anakin became a
protege of obi-wan Kenobi like there's
all these things that are being written
that all these things that are being
done in order to make sense of all this
stuff and so it's pretty awesome this is
not they're not resting on their laurels
you know with the force awakens they're
definitely working their asses
to make sure that this you know that in
place of the Expanded Universe it used
to be there is a new expanded universe
that's just as rich and just as as fun
to check out so I'm I'm pretty hyped
thoughts on a Punisher TV series on
netflix see that's interesting and it
makes sense I don't know if any of you
guys caught the news but Marvel said I
think maybe was a rumor as far as I the
last thing I saw Marvel said they were
kicking around the idea of replacing
iron fist with a Punisher TV series not
know about you guys but I'm really
psyched about that i'm actually really
hyped the punisher i think is a much
better character than danny r and in
terms of like the Cinematic Universe on
netflix the darker nature of the shows
Punisher will be a much better character
to give a solo series to Danny Rand is
cool but he's not Punisher cool and so
definitely peanut butter peanut butter
and jelly I don't know why you'd
separate the two we don't we don't
segregate here on this channel we don't
discriminate all right there's no
separate medieval peanut butter and
jelly go together we do not segregate
them so um but no I really think that'd
be a better idea to go with a go with a
Punisher show and then I than an iron
fist show so um let's see the movie's
name is a Rob can you show us your etsy
oh and Vader mural funny story i never
got it and so i contacted the company
and i was like so I never got the poster
that you guys are supposed to send me
and they were like well I mean you know
where we're you know getting a reading
we're sending it out to you it almost
dude the poster was there already i got
kept him hauling around acid here's do
man i was like it's been a month I was
like if you guys don't refund my money
right now I'm gonna get a lawyer and I'm
gonna take my money back and so they
have my money refunded by the next day
so that's that so I got 150 bucks by you
know but instead I went and bought those
yeah so um let's see uh Netflix should
do a century I'll juice entry would make
one hell of a show shadow they did a
rival Reynold show man and it only needs
to be you could you could literally make
it just like a self-contained series
your say it's in the normal Cinematic
Universe but it's not and just say like
it's it's it's isolated it's just kind
of like a one-shot like the equivalent
of a one-shot for the morrow Cinematic
Universe you know it's isolated or they
could do
like Marvel Knights they could literally
say here's Marvel Knights a different
take on Marvel characters you know it's
self-contained and just go from there
like that would be badass so my opinion
on people boycotting star wars because
the main characters black as far as i
know that was started by a troll but if
you guys are following me on twitter
like i was trolling those people like i
was i was posting up like memes with
Lando Calrissian and it was amazing so
um yeah no I don't screw around with my
money like that's not something I'm okay
with so I mean if you guys dropped 150
dollars on something and didn't get it
and let you do the same thing so century
would be good on HBO but I mean on
netflix you don't need to have him on
HBO so isn't the soup the century of
Superman ripoff yeah of course he is
like definitely you know and he was more
interesting in Marvel Knights he sucked
when he got rolled over by Jojo kisara
if you guys have learned nothing on my
channel up to this point you've probably
learned that people hate Joe casada like
well the fans do not like him so um
let's see I'd enjoy midnight midnight
would be okay for a forest series i mean
i'd check it out but you know he's
Batman basically he also his heroes
reborn again show heroes are born is a
good show it's good that it's a
miniseries because I could see how this
could go disastrously wrong but um no
it's not that at all I mean pretty
decent so
did you hear about the Batman repa or
about and trilogy as far as I know if
you were if you're if I'm thinking the
same thing you're talking about Ben
Affleck said he wanted to do a whole
trilogy like a new trilogy on Batman I'm
not against it I'd rather see how he
does in the Batman vs Superman film I
have a feeling he'll do amazing you know
but you know i'd rather see how he
performs and batman vs superman as
opposed to jumping into end of the hole
and like I saw does not work that is not
terrible but him as an as an editor in
chief was not the best decision but but
not like you know as in terms of that
member Superman I want to see how he
performs there you know before I say
yeah I'm really hyped for new batman
trilogy so um let's see I think century
character is deep which netflix could
exploit well see my preference for this
century for Robert Reynolds is the
original run is the the Marvel Knights
you know six-issue series or whatever it
was you know this century like the J
Lincoln or J lenience the Paul Jenkins
jlee run of the character like that's
what I preferred you know was that
version of this century having said that
you know I think that when they roll him
over into the moment so the main
universe didn't know what to do with him
they were just kinda like we don't know
what to do with a guy like this he's
really strong we can't nervous powers
you know so it was it was a kind of drug
his stories down so um my thoughts on
the killing joke telling jokes an
amazing story one of the best Batman
stories ever written so definitely um
thoughts on ant-man and the wasp I mean
there ok let me they're not that great
to me as a character
Rob what comics have you enjoyed the
most so far well see here's what here's
a problem you know there's only like a
couple comics from DC that I really
enjoyed the moment um Superman truth I'm
really enjoying Batman's run up until
Jim Gordon's kind of a cool take on the
character it was fun at first but then
it started to wear thin that would have
been a great like 10 issue series and it
should have just like make sure to
captain at that as opposed to like let's
see how far we can take this like you
know that that wasn't really a big fan
of you know the Green Lantern is kind of
cool although I'm a few issues behind so
I need to catch up and you know on the
Marvel end it's really just like Iron
Man and spider-man but at this point
they haven't really really grow I guess
uncanny Avengers 2 but at this point
they haven't really released any stories
that I'm digging like I don't really
like carnac I don't really find um you
know I don't I haven't read injustice
pardon me I believe it or not I haven't
read injustice I know it's love it I
know people really really think it's a
cool concept and it seems like it you
know and at this point it seems like
they've walked away from the comics at
least if I understand what Benny and Sal
were saying I'm sorry the coverage they
walked away from the video game with the
comics and so now it's just a totally
isolated story on itself and people
really really enjoy injustice but no
right now I'm looking forward to like in
I guess Ultimates is one that I'm really
looking forward to I'm looking forward
to the Miles Morales spider-man you know
there's a few others or you know there
aren't a whole lot of all new all
different titles that I'm looking
forward to that I am that I'm really
really hyped about I'm just kind of like
I mean there there you know the
interesting but I'm not going crazy over
so is that a return of the jedi poster
and yeah that's a return of the jedi pro
so those are all going to get put up
they just came in yesterday so i was
taking him out examining i'm making sure
that they they're good and not mess up
or anything like that so um let's see uh
Matthew McConaughey is that a more long
people keep saying that I don't think
that's a good choice that's not jessica
jones i'm hype for Jessica Jones I've
got two or three videos about our
character like I'm really excited about
it so let's see yeah I've seen the
jessica jones trailer so many people are
hyped about Jessica
was funny so damn dude you're hot I did
not imagine you look like that i don't
think i'm that hot but i appreciate it
there are there are women who agree with
you um hey Rob for the big 500k am I
going to ascend to the heavens and
become God no but uh no I'm not no um
let's see do you think they'll ever do
a/b honor cameo in the inhuman movie no
I don't think so because that's
something the fans didn't really like
they didn't really like the whole redcon
of the rihanna being like part mutant
party at part and human it was weird it
was it seemed like it was unnecessary
yeah but um let's see Jaden Smith for
Adam warlock do you think DC is rushing
into their cinematic universe not at all
I think DC is doing a great job with
their cinematic universe you know what
they're you know with like suicide squad
coming out that's something I'm really
excited about because that's something
model hasn't done yet muffle hasn't
given us like a gritty team if you don't
ask gritty characters you know I mean
you got daredevil you got Jessica Jones
coming out you got probably the punisher
at some point in the future you got you
know Luke Cage and they're going to be
great you know ground level gritty
characters with a lot of violence in
their shows and so that i'm looking
forward to but you know in terms of the
whole agus the whole DC Cinematic
Universe you know they're going in
directions that are really going to be
amazing at least I think so you know the
issue that DC has in their cinematic
universe are their TV shows you know
they've got flash and arrow crossing
over but Supergirl isn't in that same
continuity so um
I've got some water on my um do I like
Frank Miller's Batman of course he
doesn't like Frank Miller's Batman and
that's what I want to know what is
uncanny mean it means this uncanny
uncanny was a term that was made popular
during chris claremont one of the x-men
and so now you know it seems it's if you
tag uncanny on to the beginning of a
title people are like oh it's like it's
like that reminds me of clermont sex man
you know obviously it's going to be good
they go and buy it they read it they
make your decision from there and they
decide to continue reading it or to stop
reading it so that's all it is it's just
the way to draw fans into a title so but
what's what's interesting is actually I
guess it's a misnomer to say that it was
Chris Claremont if you go back and you
look at mmm yeah if you go back and you
look chronologically the Inhumans use
the phrase uncanny before anybody else
and so for uncanny and humans it's
actually return you know in terms of the
title but but yeah so um that's three
this song is amazing sometimes I mix
really badass songs kind of shock myself
so am I ready for dark 93 I mean I'll
read it but I'm not I'm not like on the
edge of my seat you know dying to smash
into my comic book store and buy in so
um let's see Rob does canes have the
best chicken ever or one yeah it has a
visible I would say the best chicken
ever but it has good chicken so we have
a place here in town called Indies do
that place is nuts like when the bars
let out at like 230 people will go there
and the line will be backed up for an
hour like it's nuts
Oh see Rob what is your favorite Jeff
Jones book um probably Geoff Johns Green
Lantern run like his entire Green
Lantern run it's see here's like people
don't understand like it's you know
people don't like a lot of people who
are getting into Green Lantern don't
understand what Geoff Johns did for the
Green Lantern title so so let me break
it down like a fraction you know with
regards to what what chef john's did for
the Green Lantern series so you had like
Hal Jordan right and and he had a series
of issues as titles were cancelled you
know fairly consistently he bounced
around a lot it was this issue of trying
to figure out ways to make him popular
trying to figure out ways to make him
stand out trying to make him interesting
and it just never really worked and so
all that came to a head in Emerald
Twilight and emerald Twilight they
killed him off they replaced him with a
more with a younger version with a more
cooler version I guess you know of of a
character and the form of kyle rayner
and kyle rayner was a great character
the fans loved because we're Hal Jordan
used you know his ring to create giant
fists and different structures and stuff
like that and you know spheres and
jackhammers and someone um Kyle Rayner
would create like anime characters you
know and different things like that he
used his powers in a really unique way
i'm working with my e-cig right now so
give me a second but he used his powers
in a really unique way and fans love
that concept they love seeing him do
that well the problem was you know
because it wasn't Hal Jordan and because
a Green Lantern title was never really
that popular to begin with you know as
time progressed the sales began to slip
off and so DC said okay fine like we
need to find a way to make the Green
Lantern series popular again we got to
do something no because he was on the
Justice League and he was kind of one of
the original characters they couldn't
just get rid of they could just kill him
off and so plus DC doesn't really like
get rid of characters I just kind of
shuffle them around you know but
nonetheless so they so they said okay
let's bring in Jeff Jones because geoff
johns had different runs and different
things over the course of you know
publication histories and so on and so
they brought in Jeff Jones Jeff Jones
looked at the entire Green Lantern
history look at the entire history of
the Green Lantern Corps and the Green
Lantern's were you know the green enter
college were divided into three concepts
you had the Green Lantern Corps
you had the guardians of the universe
and you had Sinestro with the yellow
lantern ring and that was it that's all
you had that's literally all there was
and he said you know what let's expand
on this and so he created entities you
know prior to Geoff Johns run of the
Green Lantern there were no there was no
parallax like Oh parallax was a name
that Hal Jordan took parallax didn't
exist it wasn't an actual entity all it
was was that Green Lantern rings could
not affect the color yellow because of
an impurity and that's all it was like
that's the only answer we ever got and
there was just never really anything
that went too far into it what Geoff
Johns did is he said nope there's an
actual entity that is a living
embodiment of fear that was confined in
the central battery core and his name is
parallax he feeds on fear he uses the
color yellow that's why Green Lantern
rings can't affect the killer yellow
because they literally can't affect
anything that has fear and that's why
you know one of the reasons why the
Green Lantern Corps became so popular
because after that it was like like we
were off to the races you know Geoff
Johns was releasing stuff and it was it
was absolutely not you add you know this
huge expanse you had all these Lantern
cores and stuff now you had you know you
had him bringing back star sapphire and
saying star sapphires or lanterns
basically they have you know lanta
drinks and you had um oh you had a the
Sinestro Corps you know now it wasn't
just Sinestro he had his own Lantern
Corps you know with yellow rings you had
the rage of the Red Lanterns you had to
know the Red Lantern Corps you had the
Black Lantern Corps you know all this
different stuff he had all these things
that he just like he expanded on and
made the Green Lantern mythos massive in
scale he effectively single-handedly
rebooted the whole thing and that's why
why Green Lantern fans love him so much
is because he changed the entire Green
Lantern mythos made it popular one guy
did that and that's why he's still
revered as one of you know DC's best
writers is because of everything he did
for the Green Lantern run so um let's
see what could Black Panther do with the
Infinity Gauntlet now that he got it
from strange well obviously he doesn't
really want it but the powers
overwhelming the power is intoxicated
but he's intelligent enough that he
could use it effectively so he may use
it but I don't know what this one we I
have no idea what he's going to do with
it so um do you think all the characters
and marvel civil war
never seen on screen will be in captain
america civil war and I'm at someone I
don't think so as far as I know they've
got the cast laid out already there we
already know what they're going to do we
already know what characters are going
to have we may have like little cameos
you know but they're not going to be
mainstays in the end the film we may
even see them you know referencing
characters or something like that but my
favorite Lantern ring is the Red Lantern
ring so world war hulk thoughts and
opinions well meanwhile we're hope was a
pool [ __ ] or a cool comic I mean it was
I mean it was cool seeing the whole
freaking out destroying people but it
wasn't you know I don't think it was
anything spectacular you know let's see
Rob any ideas on why Marvel is taking so
long to release number ones from Miles
Morales and inspire malicious David
office is to give Peter Parker at least
I would argue is to give Peter Parker a
chance to have his stories told me Peter
Parker is a flagship spider-man and so
you had to know he was going to come
first but you know it was a chance to
get you know Peter Parker's story out
there and then give people an idea of
what kind of what kind of stories it
would be seeing you know they give Dan
slots run a chance to actually breathe
and then once that happens then to
release Miles Morales or it could just
be the dance class building up to the
route to the introduction of mouse while
so it's also something that could happen
too so I don't know um what do you think
about new 52 Green Arrow I really
haven't read him to be honest Rob what
are your thoughts on Superman truth one
of the best Superman stories in the last
20 years to be honest so a DC needed to
do that hey Rob are the old continuities
star wars books or games that you oh
that i would suggest well i really
wouldn't suggest any of them to be
honest you know from the expanded
universe you know it doesn't really it
doesn't really apply anymore so you'd be
reading stuff that doesn't matter you
know but if you really want to get into
it you can go back and read about the
origins of the Jedi you know like I'm
rob explains I'll be touching on that
kind of stuff you know the origins of
the Jedi and I'll make it clear that you
know this is expanded universe of it may
not apply anymore unless Marvel or
Disney chooses to incorporate it in
but um you know nonetheless so those are
those are things that I may be touching
on over there but uh but now I mean at
this point you know it's kind of you
know all right let's let's start this
again Oh second
freakin what you will call it mixcloud
mix collabs okay but they can be a real
hassle at times um can you explain what
is happening to the x-men and the
Inhumans and only all different Marvel
we don't know we really don't know um
they started fighting eight months prior
and they've been in a civil war ever
since we have no idea that's the issue
with all new waters and waffle it
literally starts off in the middle of
everything and you're just kind of like
what the hell's going on like you know
this doesn't make any sense so oh yeah
the Jedi Outcast games were amazing star
wars knights of the old republic was
amazing um there were some stories that
were phenomenal you know from DC comic
or from Star Wars back in the day so uh
let's see Rob hell with her to infinity
gone I don't I read the Infinity
Gauntlet and then I just kind of stopped
after a while so at this point guys like
I'll be honest with you all you know
with Secret Wars I don't really care too
much i'm releasing it because i want to
have the sword completed and because for
people who were going to get into marvel
comics like I've got an all new all
different Marvel playlist going right
now which covers you know all the
different things you know everything
that led up to all move all different
Marvel including secret wars going into
only wall different model and so you
know I'm releasing that you know as an
ongoing playlist or I guess it's a
playlist that will stop when Secret Wars
finishes and so that people can know
where to go they can know what to do you
know when what everything that's the
only reason why I'm releasing it right
now I don't expect it to be popular and
I'm not expecting it to perform well but
I just want to have it completed so
let's see Rob plans on getting
battlefront 3 um I'm making it I'm kind
of thinking about it not a hundred
censure let's see okay thanks for
history
Rob are you reading Batman and Robin
eternal and if so how how do you like
her so far I actually haven't read it
but I've heard it's really good like
Joel was swearing by the other day um he
was he with Joel was was like it's solid
like you really need to read it so I'm
hope we check it out um in favorite
video game Skyrim definitely uh let's
see are you planning to do more videos
on robbery you may do creepypasta on
robberies that's weird I don't know what
creepypasta is what's creepy pasta so
what is somebody in chat explain to me
what creepypasta is I have no idea so
your casts or your thoughts on the cast
of Power Rangers movie so far I'm pretty
hyped um I think it's cool they're going
to be launching that movie I don't know
if it's I think it's official i'm not
home since um up sure really sure where
that stands but i think the cast looks
fine so I'm interested in it like I'm
excited for it Dragon Ball Z videos
you'll find those on Keanu Rob explains
so um Rob what are your thoughts on
cosmic Marvel favorite cosmic character
uh who favorite cosmic character is
definitely on yes is to get a 100 watt
plus favorite cosmic characters is
probably Adam warlock Adam warlock is
Adam warlocks like Jesus so creepy pasta
is like an urban legend for the Internet
ok off to check it out so scary internet
story could your pastas
okay it's an alternate site for urban
legends okay um yeah you're in Portugal
and I'm awesome you're in Portugal
watching this you're awesome um Rob what
are your thoughts on the upcoming phase
three films and how they'll tell god
we've answered that question so many
times I'm excited for the phase three
films we finished it though so many
times internet okay i'll definitely
check out creepypasta then because i
love campfire stories so Rob have you
read attack on Titan no I haven't but
i've heard it's pretty awesome i haven't
read a lot of indie books to be honest
you know right now I don't have time to
to be honest with you all so which by
the way this week I'm thinking about
doing like Marvel Zombies I mean it's
gonna be Halloween week and so there's
gonna be halloween videos but um you
know I'm thinking that that i might do
like like marvel zombies from you know
because here's all right here's for
those of you guys who are curious
mooreville zombies is weird and the
reason why Marvel Zombies is weird is
because they back themselves into a
corner initially Marvel Zombies was just
like introduced like it was just there
and like the century showed up from some
alternate universe and like eight
everything like killed everyone and it
was like what the hell is going on like
it was you know he infected people
spread the zombie apocalypse and and
what ended up happening was at the end
of the S at the end of zombies marvel
zombies return they said it was like a
self-fulfilling prophecy like it was a
it was a weird situation where this
century and that reality I think or
something like that was sit back and
created like this this loop created this
alternate lukla this century like they
ended up jumping into another reality
they consume that reality and then they
were sent back to the first one and so
he was it was this weird but you know
who's blue Marvel that's Adam Brashear
um yeah it's weird but I'm thinking
about like this week doing like some
zombie stories so like batman superman
vs zombies marvel zombies punisher vs
zombies vs marvel zombies that i think
is going to be kind of kind of
I wish there was like a Black Lantern
Corps vs marvel zombies comic that would
be [ __ ] amazing like I'd be so hyped
so yeah I'm pretty hyped can I explain
my voice I guess have I seen the four so
we can see no I haven't but that's where
somebody like put all the all the scenes
together right now I haven't seen that
I'm not going to because I don't want to
spoil anything for myself so um god i'm
so hyped for Star Wars like I'm so
excited let's see since you're going to
cover Marvel Zombies during Halloween do
you think Marvel Zombies maybe would
work out oh I'd be hyped for Marvel
Zombies movie like I think would work
out fine yeah um let's see a loop is
Bruce Willis have anything know that
you're thinking of looper let's see what
do you think mom will release civil war
trailer um probably around Christmas in
fact I'd say it'll probably come out
with a Star Wars to be honest that make
perfect sense you know it'll probably
come out with the Star Wars film I don't
know why I wouldn't see
uh what do I think of death battle I
haven't seen it thoughts on flash season
2 I think flash season 2 is actually
coming along pretty good um i like i
like the idea of i'm jay garrick staying
and i was really hoping he would and i
already did a video on Richard rider I'm
really glad that he's staying and I was
kind of afraid you know when they are
gonna in like the first you know a
couple episodes that he was going to end
up going back and you know obviously who
you'll get a speedster power back I mean
you know it'll be towards the end but
he'll get a speedster power back and and
it will be really cool to see like the
two of them you know side by side like
that'll be the cool thing but if you
guys saw the first the first sees the
first episode I think it was when Jay
Garrick had like pretended that he still
had his powers there's a scene at the
end when the cop is like when when they
killed when Barry Allen kills a villain
and the cop falls and you know she's
like flash help and like they come
running towards her and they go around a
brick wall that's a direct homage to
flash or to worse so Falacci worlds
rather from the cover of that comic is
to direct a direct shot from that um
let's see uh Walking Dead 90 minute
episode thoughts nope oh wait there's a
90 minute episode coming out no there's
not let's see childress Linton has the
ancient one in the MCU best casts oh
yeah Tilda Swinton is amazing she's an
amazing actress like I love her
character or love her as a person rather
I mean not you know like it she's a
great actress and great actress and the
rules is she plays so in an effort to
keep standing out keep them setting
awkward we're just going to move on so
um let's see if new 52 Superman and Goku
ever have a crossover would you rather
the story plays out where they faced
each other or team up to fight i love
the CM team up and fight well it would
be like Batman vs Superman we're likely
fight at first and then they team up
later on like that would make more sense
so Rob if you were new to the Marvel
comic book world what would be the first
comic books that you would read
uh probably only well different Marvel
like that would be my that's where I
would start with Marvel Comics and then
with DC I'd pick a character and read
the run that's the issue you know with
character runs its you got to start from
the beginning you know it's really
difficult well not sometimes you do
sometimes you don't but it's really
difficult to to build into it so let's
see Gotham season to you I'm not a big
fan of Gotham I've seen it I didn't like
it I watched half of the first season
and lost interest so how would I feel
like them if I made her if they made a
Robin solo film I'd watch it I think
it'd be cool I mean if it was based on
like Jason Todd or if it was like under
the red hood you know like an actual
live action film I'd watch that I think
it'd be pretty cool so if new 52 you
Superman met pre-new fatigue Superman
who would win we'll find out because DC
is releasing a comic when they have a
common going on right now called The
Adventures of Lois and Clark were
basically they're saying that like pre
new 52 Superman has been in the new 52
continuity since it launched he's been
here the entire time from the very
beginning he saw the Justice League
fighting dark side and he's been
operating behind the scenes so it's
actually a pretty cool concept um let's
see good morning galaxy rain was my
opinion of one more day still being
cannon I may make sense yeah it you know
it makes sense that is still going to be
candid so let's see what do you think
about the new Wonder Woman costume and
batman vs superman dawn of justice I'm
not really concerned about a costume so
much as I'm concerned about the actress
cuz i gross skinny as hell and I got to
tell you like Wonder Woman suppose to be
an Amazon so she's supposed to be like a
huge in size yeah I used to smoke
cigarettes he supposed to be big in size
in terms of like you know her stature or
physical presence you know she's
supposed to be a very full-figured woman
and like this real skinny a [ __ ] and so
like if you know it's going to be
ridiculously unbelievable you know if
some girl goes running out there with
some scrawny ass legs you know it's
gonna be like you know what like don't
even know
and women are going to be pissed like
phileus groups are going to come out and
like lambaste that film that's not a
true representation of what a amazon
would look like they're all that
political nonsense so let's see favorite
Star Wars comic the origin of the Jedi
you know that are like force wars I
think it was called force worse Batman
very Superman would you like to see a
sequel to the dread film back in 2011 no
I think that was a great standalone film
I think it's great to keep it where it
is and not really add anything to it
because they do they stand to screw up
both movies so what's beyond the source
of all I am I'm beyond the source wall
so skinny shaming oh yeah that wasn't
was one of the things like like I was I
was talking I was a kind of thrown my
thoughts out there the other day and I
was talking about the souper the Super
Girl TV show and obviously it's going to
be a show about a girl who's on the
planet trying to find her place in the
world and I was like yes that was like
an attractive white girl into the 21st
century America it's clearly the best
candidate to demonstrate what it means
to struggle in society like definitely
the best route to go with that character
so I can tell you right now that element
is going to be just like absolutely
hammered on its going to get stomped on
the ground by a lot of people let's see
quick question Rob would you rather 500
excised horses or Oh 500 duck-sized
horses or one duck sized horse or one
horse-sized duck okay um I played would
you rather uh let's see I don't know I'd
rather fight a fight like one duck set
one for size of duck that'd be awesome
so it'd be pretty badass um let's see
Carol Danvers versus Supergirl
we're not doing any more of those um
Alicia's autumn Miller yeah what are
your thoughts on the Hulk and Thor
Ragnarok I'm actually really excited um
you know obviously it'll be banner you
know helping to even the odds it'll be
interesting because that never happened
and for Ragnarok he was Iron Man and
Captain America that teamed up with Thor
during the Ragnarok event so I'm
actually really curious to see what they
do with this because this is uncharted
water as far as I'm concerned so do i
watch agent of shield season 3 yes and
and I have my thoughts on agents of
shield season 3 like I've already got my
my opinions my beliefs on the direction
of the show where things are going what
happened to Jenna Simmons why she has to
go back that kind of thing so um best
Batman movie Batman mask of the phantasm
hands down the best Batman movie of all
time now let's see imagine a blind
Superman that actually be pretty
hilarious like a blind Superman like his
eyes were gouged it out by I dark side
or something like that they had be
pretty funny I mean his eyes getting
gouged that would not be funny but like
a blind Superman well that I don't know
like I think it'd be got a funny oh yeah
I know why they can't be in it but I'm
because the Ragnarok took place during
Avengers disassembled so you know the
the chronic chronology of events are
different in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they are in the show so raw
us in the comics so let's see what do I
think of age of apocalypse oh he was a
cool story from back in the day so mi pc
bruh yeah i'm part of the pc master race
that really small number of people that
are grossly outmatched by like console
gamers yeah like I'm and then that's
that's one of the funny things about
like PC gamers is it it's like I'm
fiercely protective of being a pc gamer
why because there's so few of us are you
going to go kamikaze yeah that's what
we're going to los angeles force
kamikaze
best Joker story Emperor Joker hands
down one of the best Joker stories I'd
say number one might well but number one
swell be a toss-up between my opinion
between Emperor Joker and the killing
joke so I'm sure all his other super
senses would allow Superman to see ya
the same ways daredevil yeah I agree I
mean that makes sense to me so Rob who
is your favorite Robin mmm probably uh
probably Jason Todd he was a pretty
awesome awesome Robin I think let's go
all on gmod later I applied Gary MA
garry's mod like twice and it was weird
so I just never played it again there
was one guy running around as sonic and
there were Rainbows coming up behind him
like he was just a weird ass place it
was it was literally like it was walking
it's like like you ever had those those
dreams were you going to like an
alternate reality and things are so
insane that like like your sanity has
tested its push to the point where you
don't know if you'll ever come back the
same way again like that's what it was
like playing garry's mod except for when
I played um prop one that game was fun
as hell so let's see China from WWE as
Wonder Woman No now by a long shot no
dear god no opinions on John Cena John
Cena is pretty amazing he said he's
actually a really cool guy with all the
charity and everything yet so Rob you
read idw's transformers yet what are
your thoughts on the direction no I
haven't read transformers
uh let's see I mean I tried doing some
indie comics like I did the walking dead
and that people didn't really seem to
like that too it's not the best
performing series on my channel so the
people like people on my channel don't
seem to like anything but marvel comics
so like Marvel and maybe like some DC
depending on what the story is so um
let's see thoughts on Captain America
death in Civil War I think that'll
happen definitely if not will happen
very soon after so i had a dream that I
knew what happened in Budapest with
Natasha and Clint okay what did you what
do you think happened so Rob what is the
perfect woman a woman that like connects
with you on a personal level let's see
what is your favorite member of the bad
fit oh who is okay who sought to
remember the bat family again Jason Todd
as the as the Red Hood definitely like
he's pretty solid so um let's see is
your family proud of a YouTube success
oh yeah my friends and family are pretty
pretty psyched Tyrone Magnus and Rob
teemo do I'd love the team up with
Tyrone Magnus like I do be hilarious do
you like a reaction video would be fun
but a cantar Oh Magnus man like that guy
let me tell you something guys want to
talk about going from 0 to 60 like I was
following Tyrone Magnus and he was a
subscriber of mine like a long time ago
um I was I felt a Tyrone Magnus you know
like equity had fifty sixty thousand
subscribers and that guy's channel went
from just BAM exploded out of nowhere
and and he's taken off so fast like it's
pretty it's pretty awesome to see um
let's see Ronda Rousey as she hulk I
know Ronda Rousey is Captain Marvel
let's see how bad will Suicide Squad
movies suck because of Jared Leto why
would you take that attitude like why
why would you take that opinion just
like immediately be like the movies
going to suck because it has this one
guy that's a stupid attitude to have
very rarely will i ever say your opinion
stupid but your opinion is stupid like
that's a stupid attitude to take so um
any opinions on YouTube red
I mean I'm never going to use it at
least not unless I'm forced to so I'm
not using it right now I mean I don't
it's not even available to me it's
available to YouTube's taught top and
most popular content creators so you
know there's no reason for me to use it
at the moment so I mean it's fine it's a
cool concept I guess I mean they're like
three years behind the curve you know
but it's a cool concept so um let's see
Robin your opinion what are the best
Batman bad family stories and what is
the best order to read them in oh damn
that's one hell of a question that's
Batman bad family that's that's another
question for another time like that's
that's a 20 minute answer um it should
how hard he plays someone in the MCU uh
yeah Tom are you should play The
Punisher jon bernthal will be a great
Punisher but Tom Hardy I think will be
better so are we going to see eternity
and others in the MCU yeah we've already
seen them so I don't mean and Guardian
Toronto mean ant-man like we saw them in
guardians of the galaxy most anticipated
dcu movie aside from Batman vs Superman
Suicide Squad the only movies they have
coming out i think in the the immediate
moment i'm pretty sure that's the case
it could be wrong but pretty sure that's
it let's see r is scott snyder and zack
snyder related both connected to Batman
as far as I know yeah they related
they're brothers I think pretty sure so
is that a London poster yes that's
Lenin's it's a picture of him and it's
got the lyrics to imagine on it so let's
see hey Rob for someone new to model
college do you think it'll be worth
catching up on all the big Marvel events
the past decade no just go buy the
characters start with all new all
different level and go by each
individual each individual story that
you want to read just take it that way
it's the easiest way to do it so see
what's your favorite Suicide Squad comic
series I was a big fan of Suicide Squad
um it was kind of cool with the new 52
but you know I think to me
the movies weren't reading the comics
I'm not even sure why they made a movie
because the comics were constantly
cancelled and constantly brought back
like you were all kinds of different you
know issues going on with a Suicide
Squad it was never one of dc's best
stories and so on never really took the
time to get into it let's see uh well I
talked about idw comics like Ninja
Turtles and transformers uh yeah
probably you know but if the video
doesn't meet my threshold of success and
probably won't do it again so let's see
what happens um let's see The Magus
fur-face for with Thanos being recruited
for the infant nasty I can almost
guarantee you that's not going to happen
can alter on return when Thanos kills
vision uh I don't know I don't think so
as far as we know he killed killed
Ultron that may not have been the case
but as far as we know he destroyed last
Ultron robot so Rob could you start
putting the music using your videos in
the description there's a slow bluesy
guitar at the beginning of old man Logan
I've seen I've been looking for okay oh
yeah I'm all we start doing that I can't
tell you how long I remember to do it
but I'll start doing that let's see do
you think Peter Parker or any hero in
the MCU will die by the end of phase 3
um no I don't think so Oh his ex lighter
and Scott Snyder are not related okay
that's fine I didn't know if they were
related or not I was kind of assume they
were you know but I was 100 said sure um
see what's my current favorite song
something better by audion it's an
amazing song there's also God there was
one song I heard a remix of that was
incredible but there's also the there's
degrees of motion do you want it now
that was remixed by
[ __ ] emanuel and somebody else and it's
a pretty awesome song too so it's more
of like a progressive house on but it's
pretty cool Freddy Krueger or Jason
definitely Jason a lot of clams casino
escas clams casino was amazing cool
posters in the back thank you ah ah so
many questions coming in wyd sabe or rob
zombie uh I never really listened to two
white zombie when Rob Zombie was a lead
singer so i mostly listen to just Rob
Zombie's stuff Rob Zombie was pretty
solid you know I mean Dracula is
obviously a classic everybody knows what
that song is and so um bit any thoughts
on Ben Affleck is Deathstroke I don't
know about that theory that Ben Affleck
his destro I'd be over the moon if they
release a Deathstroke movie I'd be
really happy about that like to be
badass like Sam Elliott playing
Deathstroke would be freaking amazing um
Bryan Cranston is Lex Luthor I would so
check that out Bryan Cranston would be a
perfect guy to play lex luthor you know
the problem is people would look at him
as Lex Luthor and they would be like
he's like he's like a you know Walter
White for Breaking Bad he's Heisenberg
like that's that's the one that's the
bryan cranston they would want to see
the people would want to see so um
there's a ghost behind you Oh Dan well I
guess I'm about to die um let's see uh
thoughts on Jessica Jones trailer ooh um
I mean I liked it I'm pretty sight so
Henry Rollins is naked oh definitely I'm
pretty psyched on jessica jones i think
the trailer was cool i mean it didn't
really show us a whole lot you know but
it's a cool concept I'm digging it
either way ah let's see
what are your thoughts on the deathlok
of agents of shield and I don't really
care about Deathlok too much to be
honest yes I'm a Lex Luthor thing yeah I
mean John had no I think no no way I
think Henry Rollins is Megan would be
pretty awesome and I'm really hyped
about Nagin to his Nagin was man i got
was twisted so like that guy is really
really twisted um Bryan Cranston is Jim
Gordon Bryan Cranston is everybody let's
see favorite video game I already
answered that Skyrim thoughts on an
arkham game on Nightwing or Robin oh I'd
play a Nightwing arkham game I think
it'd be pretty stellar like I'd really
enjoy that um let's see now there's
somebody in the chat that's trying to
troll I mean you know like they were
typing something in than they laughed
like here's here's a little a little bit
of a tidbit for for all the trolls out
there if you were funny you wouldn't
have to laugh at your own jokes so
thoughts on Black Panther on the big
screen oh I might definitely um do you
agree that new 52 Joker is terrible no
new 52 Joker's amazing like he's an
incredible cared like I love that new
video feed Joker he's darker he's more
sinister you know he's still funny like
it's a really really dark twisted human
i love that version of Joker so I think
it's one of the best versions of the
joke in a long time to be quite honest
favorite Batman run Oh new 52 Batman is
actually pretty amazing Scott Snyder has
done wonders for his character um he's
not as like evolved or as wise as the
previous new 52 version but um but no
like I think that that you know the the
Batman that we're seeing now in the Navy
t2 is pretty solid it was a pretty great
character so
what I pay fifty dollars to see a live
action movie where the Avengers go
against the Justice League yeah who
wouldn't Don River Plate warframe so
thoughts on Superman bashing I'm a well
people don't like Superman I mean just
cuz the person says I don't like
Superman doesn't mean they're bashing on
Superman amines I don't like Superman
they're entitled to hate Superman as
much as you're entitled to love a
Superman um am I gonna play fallout 4
hell yeah hey Rob I'm opening up a comic
and gaming store in Las Vegas do you
have any of I don't know anything about
opening up a comic store so I can't even
begin to help you there um let's see uh
hahaha Martin Freeman is Otto Octavius
please tell us what you are okay i just
missed that so many questions just
jumped in why are you streaming so late
because i want to post them in busy this
actually rest in peace fan for stick
excited for the warcraft movie i'll go
check it out I'm always really excited
about those those sci-fi adventure
fantasy movies so I'm definitely you
know curious to see what direction it
goes in but am i playing black ops 3 now
I'm gonna get black ops 3 for zombies
but I'm not gonna be playing the
multiplayer let's see the Joker in in
game was amazing yeah that's what I'm
saying so Justice League movie which
should which comics should they adapt
over the Justice League um Justice
League new frontier like that would be a
damn good story to adapt let's see
thoughts on the silver surfer he's a
great character great cosmic character I
like the Silver Surfer because he's like
what he was initially introduced like he
was like his humanity or I guess you
know what's what passes for humanity
from from his own race was completely
white clean and he was really like a
blank slate and so discovering the
planet Earth like it really
it was you know it was it was the it was
humanity it was super heroes humanity
the whole Kyle you know all that kind of
stuff through the eyes of the silver
surfer and it was an incredible you know
incredible series to read if you ever
really want to see other ever really
want to read a great Silver Surfer story
the go read a death of the Silver Surfer
I guess silver surfer requiem like
that's one of the you know by
Straczynski I think it was one of the
best Silver Surfer stories you're ever
going to read in your life so let's see
anyway uh yeah we're going to go ahead
and bring this thing to an end we've
been doing this for about an hour guys
so I'm gonna get to work on my my series
for marvel zombies and yeah so I will
catch you guys later peace